not only is the West not uniquely or
even especially responsible for the
evils of Conquest the West in fact has
been uniquely innocent of the crimes
associated with Conquest if the growth
shrinking and movement of peoples is
inevitable that is to say if Conquest is
an inescapable fact of politics then who
would you rather be conquered by would
you rather be conquered by Christians or
Aztecs Christians or jihadis Christians
or atheists we haven't even touched on
the atheists yet The Atheist regimes
which are responsible for the worst
crimes associated with Conquest in the
20th century I sometimes tell critics of
Christian nationalism that if they think
Christian nationalism is bad just wait
until they see unchristian nationalism
the same is true of settlement
colonialism and Conquest if you believe
that the Western kind of Conquest is bad
just wait until you see all the other
kinds